well the infamous fire Festival promised
Superstars luxury and fine dining in a
Caribbean Paradise instead it became a
fiasco that left founder Billy McFarland
sentenced six years in jail owing 26
million dollars to investors which
remains unpaid here's a reminder of
what's been called the biggest fraud in
music festival history immortalized in a
hit Netflix documentary
Island Getaway turned disaster it became
very barbaric American rapper Ja Rule is
in the Bahamas with his business partner
Billy McFarland is an amazing
entrepreneur he could convince anyone at
pretty much anything they just bought an
island Pablo Escobar's Island within 48
hours
they sold out when thousands arrived in
the Bahamas for the fire Festival after
paying up to fifteen hundred dollars for
a ticket and twelve thousand dollars for
a VIP experience they found a millennial
nightmare
it was basically the exact opposite of
everything we were promised prosecutors
say cost investors and customers over 26
million dollars the promoter behind the
botched fire music festival the Bahamas
has been sentenced now to six years in
prison
well Benny muthana went to prison and he
joins me now Billy mafana thank you very
much indeed for joining me
Pierce thank you for having me on your
platform huge opportunity thank you so
look I watched the Netflix documentary
and it was like watching a slow-moving
pile up on a on a freeway for you
Motorway for us where it just seemed
pretty obvious quite early on this was
not going to work and the bigger the
hole you dug the worse things got was
that how it felt for you
well appears first you are braver than
me because I've never watched
documentaries and
still can't get myself to do it but I
was just so wrong and I'd like to I
think start with telling you what I
thought that I was trying to do
so I thought that I was taking these
different people from diverse
backgrounds and bringing them together
through adventures and experiences
and when this was happening it was
almost like I found my little slice of
magic in the world as these people were
forming relationships and sharing ideas
and I really just want to share this
with everybody and I was just so wrong
in my approach to do that well hang on
look I'm sorry but your attempt to make
yourself out to be some magic maker uh
keen on spreading diversity it all
sounds great now but the truth is you've
been trying to fleece them all for cash
that's why you ended up in prison for so
long I mean it was it was a money-making
vehicle your intention was not to you
know get a load of happy campers
together and spread love and diversity
in a bit of magic it was to empty their
wallets wasn't it
I was so wrong and
I lost everything I had in the process
and lost the support the relationships
and the trust of all of my friends and
all of my investors and all of my team
members as crazy as it sounds for me
sitting here looking back at all the
terrible decisions I made
I truly thought that I was going to pull
off this event that does not excuse the
lying to investors that I did to try to
get the capital that I thought I needed
and Pierce I was wrong I messed up I
mean you're planning another Festival
now
um called pirate I think uh which is
probably quite appropriate but why
should anybody trust you either with
money as an investment or buying a
ticket to this thing given what happened
before given you've not paid off all the
people who lost money last time
yeah that's a really good question and
in my mind there's two ways to look
there yeah in my mind there's two ways
to look at this and I think that one
option is is to essentially crawl in a
hole and die of remorse and I think
that's something a lot of people
probably want but then how does
everybody get paid and for me I need to
find pride In My Life by at least trying
to write my wrongs and make it up to
everybody that I hurt
I mean you went to prison for quite a
long time what was that experience like
he has to served around four years and I
just kept making it worse and worse upon
myself I actually ended up spending 309
days in solitary confinement so for the
first period of my life I was really
forced to sit in time out and reflect on
terrible decisions and try to understand
like what makes me tick as a human and
how I could try to do something positive
moving forward
I don't know you I know what a lot of
people have said about you it's not
flattering as you know I obviously I'm
aware a lot of people lost a lot of
money and that's a serious situation it
was a crime for which you've paid your
price and it was a pretty big price to
pay would you categorize yourself as
somebody who was you know a criminal
mastermind or somebody that perhaps
others might say was just a massive
bullshitter on the make who thought he'd
get away with it and unfortunately all
his chips fled from red to Black
I think what just disgusts me the most
pure especially during those 10 months
where I had nothing to look at like you
know but a concrete wall in myself is
that I was trying for six seven years to
build and launch startups and I formed
great relationships over those period
And the fact that I took advantage of
those relationships all for this purpose
of trying to be successful or big or
well known and it was just disgusting
and awful what's the one thing you've
really learned about yourself Billy
you just can't attach your personal
Pride to success or any idea of success
and it's more about the relationships
and the bond you find along the way and
I was just so insecure and thought that
my personal self-worth would be
executing a big Festival that made
everybody rich and happy and that's just
so incredibly wrong and it's how I can
find that pride and self-worth in my
day-to-day like regular life do you ever
wonder what would have happened if if it
had worked
yeah I think that's one of the biggest
misconceptions is even if the festival
succeeded I still would have gone to
jail like I lied to investors to raise
the money so even if people made money
and all the ticket holders met great
people and had the weekend of their
lives I would have been sitting in jail
for years so there's just no there's no
excuse peers well and to those who you
know you owe money to who are disgusted
you're having another Festival what do
you say finally to them
and once again it's like I need to find
Pride somewhere in life and my pride
hopefully in 60 years from now when I'm
on my deathbed is that I spent the
majority of my adult life trying to
write my wrongs so I'm going to go out
there and work I'm going to work
honestly I can't promise that I'm going
to succeed but I can promise I'm getting
help where I need it and trying to focus
on my skill set and whatever I do will
go towards paying everybody okay well on
one positive note you've got the right
name for the festival fire because
that's what it went all up in uh Billy
mothadone thank you for joining me I
appreciate it